[Music]
527 on your Finally Friday what's
driving you crazy maybe you need a
reminder to stay away from Cheyenne both
east and west of U.S 95 in the Northwest
Valley
like the kids say if you know you know
the city of Las Vegas been working on
sewer installations there for months
taking eastbound Cheyenne down to one
lane from Buffalo to the 95 making it
hard to go south on Tanea from westbound
Cheyenne after the freeway and still
messing with Cheyenne east of the
freeway well this weekend you won't be
able to get to Cheyenne from Northbound
us-95 the city shutting down the off
ramp at nine o'clock this evening
scheduled to run until six Monday
morning it's part of the project that
seems like it'll never end
so maybe you need to write yourself a
sticky note to get off the north 95 at
either Lake Mead or Craig a little bit
of light at the end of the tunnel city
of Las Vegas says the project is
supposed to be done by the end of next
month buckle up drive carefully please
put on that phone you can join the
driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com